[Musique]
bien bien bon tout d'abord bienvenue aux
internautes qui nous ont qui nous
rejoignent maintenant donc nous avons
commencé en début d'après-midi à
travailler sur cette conférence culture
on a voulu organiser différemment du
travail que l'on fait sur nos
conventions vous avez les conventions
des parties des forums
ensuite on a travaillé avec des groupes
plus restreints sur chacune des
conventions on débouche sur des
propositions très concrètes qui sont
systématiquement soumises aux votes de
nos militants d'ailleurs toujours avec
une très forte participation des
militants sur les les réponses à chacune
des propositions qui sont faites qui
nous permettent d'ailleurs l'occasion
des conventions de les publier
là sur cette conférence culture on est
parti sur une autre approche où on s'est
concentrés essentiellement enfin sur le
travail de terrain je le disais tout à
l'heure à 14 heures
on a voulu redémarrer du terrain pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que quand on regarde l'ensemble
des dépenses de la culture en direction
de la culture pardon en france les trois
quarts des dépenses r 75% des dépenses
se font à partir des collectivités
territoriales donc la politique
culturelle en france c'est d'abord les
collectivités territoriales 25% de
l'état qui sont éminemment important
mais la réalité au quotidien c'est les
collectivités et au premier rang
desquels de loin les villes
c'est pour ça que nous avons travaillé
avec une quarantaine de l'adjoint à la
culture dans différentes villes villes
françaises et en partant en ayant ce
souci de partir d' actions très
concrètes de terrain dix ans et vous
dans votre ville qu'est ce que vous
faites en matière de politique
culturelle quelles sont les actions
quelles sont leurs tombes et comment
vous les mettez en place comment la
population y est associée comment elle
se les approprient parce que si je
reprends mon ancienne casquette de maire
de provins
où on beaucoup là aussi investis dans la
culture avec des grands rassemblements
et puis plus de un million deux cent
mille visiteurs par an on voit bien que
la politique culturelle elle marche
lorsque la population
non seulement il adhère mais se
l'approprient et à partir du nom se
l'approprient et bien ça se déclinent
très naturellement donc au delà des
incidences budgétaires que j'évoquais on
peut aussi parler du nombre d'emplois
qui sont liées à cette politique
culturelle c'est je crois à peu près un
million trois cent mille emplois qu'on
peut estimer liées aux actions
culturelles donc on voit bien qu'il ya
une action
d'abord en matière de culture c'est
essentiel on va y revenir
il y a des retombées économiques
financières et puis il y a bien entendu
un patrimoine le spectacle vivant
beaucoup de choses dont on pourrait
quand on pourrait parler et puis il ya
très concrètement aussi des emplois au
quotidien qui ceux qui sont liés
alors toute cette après midi on a
travaillé dans trois dans trois ateliers
donc gilles platret agnès evren et annie
genevard vont venir vous présenter les
travaux de leur atelier donc on commence
cette fois-ci par gilles merci christian
je vais demander à vincent
voilà qui va être mon binôme adjointe au
maire de sharp dans des chargés des
questions de culture de venir à mes
côtés se permettre de tomber st merci
oui tu es obligé christian de leurs
maîtres
moi j'aurais peut-être dire emprunt un
préambule pour avoir rapidement échangé
avec jaillit bien mais deux colistières
jeu que je sorte quand même de mon
ambiance de campagne mais en tout cas
mes deux collègues animatrice avec moi
sur sur ce sujet c'est le caractère
absolument passionnant de ce qui s'est
passé cet après midi c'est à dire que
des élus à la culture de tout le
territoire de tous niveaux de
collectivités se retrouvent et échangent
sur des problématiques qui leur soit
propre
c'est une première je veux redire ici en
sa présence que nous la devons à jean
philippe lefebvre et
qui est président honoraire de la fncc
et je veux vraiment le remercier parce
que je veux croire christian que c'était
une première et qui pourrait y en avoir
d'autres et qui peut être d'ailleurs
pourrait concerner d'autres délégations
d'élus parce que là il est sorti un
certain nombre de choses
et soyons clairs on n'a pas eu une
journée complète
on a échangé quelques grappes de deux
minutes
et pourtant ça a été extrêmement
productif alors nous allons donc vous
présenter la conclusion en tout cas le
constat que nous tirons des échanges qui
ont été fait autour de l'attractivité
économique
on a beaucoup échangé sur les voies et
moyens c'était d'abord un retour
d'expérience et donc la façon dont nous
envisageons les choses donc d'abord
autour de la notion de culture services
à la population
on le place bien comme un service public
c'est pas neutres comme idée est en tout
cas c'est une idée qui était partagée au
sein du groupe
ensuite l'investissement puisqu'on est
sur les retombées économiques on y vient
évidemment à savoir que c'est assez de
l'argent bien placé
c'est peut-être tabou de parler d'argent
en matière de culture mais il n'y a pas
de culture s'il ya pas de moyens dégagés
et surtout les moyens investis sont
qu'entraîne font jaillir des retombées
économiques absolument fondamental sur
nos territoires et on le voit encore
plus cette année
depuis un an maintenant ou nous sommes
privés en grande partie des biens grande
partie du fait culturel
on abordera ensuite les questions de
culture et d'aménagement du territoire
où il y en a un peu d'argile certes mais
pour nous c'est essentiel c'est que ces
thématiques qui sont chers à certains
d'entre vous et enfin les enjeux c'est à
dire en gros ce sur quoi dans la
perspective parce qu'on n'a pas oublié
que nous travaillons pour préparer
l'alternance
mon cher christian quelles pourraient
être les points sur lesquels la
réflexion peut être poussées en matière
de politique culturelle et notamment
ceux qui manquent aujourd'hui aux
collectivités territoriales pour rester
fortement impliqué dans leurs actions en
matière de culture
les trois-quarts de l'action culturelle
française sont dues aux collectivités
territoriales dont comment est ce qu'on
fait pour que ce soit encore le cas
demain et que l'état qui a quand même
tendance à reprendre un peu ses billes
cela nous laisse nous débrouiller tout
seul n'entraîne pas des effets
collatéraux terrible s'il devait y avoir
des variables d'ajustement dès qu'ils
soient actionnés voilà un petit peu la
philosophie donc on va essayer de
développer en une dizaine de minutes et
ensuite on va lancer le débat avec la
salle
chers collègues allaient les services de
services à la population
merci louis voilà j'ai désigné
volontaire pour vous accompagner
effectivement le premier axe est un
constat pour nous évident que nous
sommes la culture représente déjà un
service à la population surtout nos
territoires très important avec
effectivement des axes très différent si
je prends le cas d'une médiathèque qui
peut outre le livre bien évidemment
avoir un effet de formation enfin c'est
très très large donc je ne peux pas
rentrer dans les détails parce que je
sais que c'était très court et
qu'effectivement ce temps des changes
on est toujours un petit peu frustré
parce qu on a tellement de choses à dire
il ya tellement d'expérience en tout cas
encore une fois et je salue moi aussi le
président de la fnc dont je fais partie
également pour cette initiative parce
que c'est important
voilà très bien donc je vais aller vite
mais je crois que tout le monde a besoin
de de pouvoir après peut-être échanges
et donc nous avons mis l'accent sur le
service à la population les équipements
qui font la richesse effectivement nos
territoires que ce soit la strate de la
ville de la commune du département qui a
une ingénierie très importante ça on y
reviendra peut-être évidemment après des
régions donc nous c'est vrai que l'état
aujourd'hui aide pour le développement
de certains équipements notamment les
bibliothèques c'est très important je le
sais bien
et puis tous ces équipements aujourd'hui
font la force et l'attractivité d'un
territoire puisque et ça c'est
effectivement le lien avec le modèle
économique
aujourd'hui une entreprise qui va qui va
vouloir ce qui va vouloir effectivement
s'implanter sur un territoire elle va
regarder ce que le territoire lui
propose une offre
notamment en terme d'équipements
culturels les familles viennent
s'installer effectivement il faut pas
que ce soit non plus trop plein désert
et puis les équipements sportifs mais ça
c'est dans une autre délégation mais
c'est vrai que c'est aussi également
très important et là on met on met
l'accent sur ce lien sur ce lien
équipements culture
et puis attractivité du territoire
ensuite c'est vrai que la politique
culturelle des collectivités
territoriales fait qu'on peut actionner
au niveau du territoire une économie les
festivals sont font venir effectivement
un public
on a eu plusieurs cas plusieurs exemples
que je ne vais pas détailler enfin bien
placé également gilles pour savoir ce
que ça peu ce que ça peut rentrer comme
comme économie pour le territoire
donc c'est vrai que ces vertueux puisque
en fait la culture est accessible à tous
alors par des festivals qui peuvent être
gratuits ou payants peu importe là c'est
un détail mais cette culture qui est
proposée sur le territoire va faire
venir un public ce public aussi profiter
du territoire et puis derrière et bien
il ya il y à bien oui des 10 sociétés
des commerces qui pourront qui pourront
également profiter de ce public
et j'ai vu j'ai envie de dire que c'est
un petit peu un cercle vertueux
voilà d'autres alors c'est vrai que nous
sommes nous sommes les premiers à
pouvoir accueillir les artistes en
résidence on l'a zidane ça
mais ça ça peut se faire aussi voilà
c'est un soutien fort c'est un soutien
fort des collectivités et des
collectivités qui les accueille en
résidence qui les aident à la création
résidence diffusion intéressant aussi de
voir effectivement l'interaction qu'il
peut y avoir entre les différentes
strates de collectivités c'est bien
aussi que ces compagnies qu'elles soient
alors en particulier des compagnies
effectivement professionnelles qu'elles
puissent ensuite après pouvoir diffuser
sur tout le territoire
peut-être dans un premier temps aussi
sur leur propre région puisqu'elles sont
souvent rattaché à une région alors
aujourd'hui
bien évidemment elles vont tous au
festival d'avignon pour pouvoir après
vendre vendre leurs créations mais ça
serait bien également qu'on regarde plus
en détail comment interagir entre
département commune région
ça c'était un constat mais en tout cas
c'est une force de pouvoir accueillir
toutes ces compagnies et tous ces
artistes professionnels mais nous
faisons aussi beaucoup pour les amateurs
et nous soutenons aussi beaucoup toutes
les associations ça fait partie de nos
prérogatives
merci d'une vitrine it non mais oui on
fait vite pressé surtout pour lancer le
débat sur le alors on a choisi de titrer
le deuxième sur la culture est un
investissement
il ya un enjeu alors évidemment chaque
territoire a sa propre son propre retour
sur investissement on sait que sur
certains secteurs que ce soit dans le
département dans les communes on est
pratiquement sûr un rapport de 1 à 10
c'est à dire un euro investi va générer
10 euros de chiffre d'affaires sur le
territoire ça se vend ça va être du
chiffre d'affaires directement pour les
compagnies rémunéré savez du chiffre
d'affaires pour les restaurateurs pour
les hôteliers pour toute l'économie qui
va se trouver autour de l'évènement qui
va être ainsi créés et je crois qu'il
faut ne jamais perdre de vue cela
lorsque parfois la tentation arrive de
baisser un petit peu la garde ou de
baisser le niveau d'investissement dans
une collectivité
il faut voir les répercussions que ça en
matière économique
ce sont des répercussions directes ça ne
veut pas dire parce que
nous arrachera jamais notre adn de bon
gestionnaire
ça veut pas dire que il faut mettre sans
cesse plus d'argent pour que l'argent
soit mieux géré je pense que je fais
appel ici à la responsabilité des élus
un euro peut être mieux gérés pour que
avec un euro on est finalement le même
service que là on l'avait avec 2 mais
simplement ce que nous soulignons c'est
que l'argent investi est un retour
direct sur le territoire c'est pas pour
autant que l'on souhaite forcément créer
on l'a dit des rentes de situation
lorsqu'on parle des moyens qui sont mis
en direction des artistes et c'est vrai
que la politique de résidence s'est
énormément développée depuis 20 ans
énormément
rappelez-vous nos collectivités il ya
vingt ans il y avait très très peu de
résidences d'artistes aujourd'hui que ce
soit dans les collectivités les régies
autonomes personnalisé ou pas on a une
politique de résidence sur les scènes
nationales ou à rayonnement régional
donc on voit bien qu'il ya une volonté
d'aider au projet et pas forcément de
créer des rentes de situation notamment
lorsqu'on s'adresse à au secteur privé
qu'on va accompagner financièrement
laurent bouquet le le président du
territoire de belfort nous disait que
son objectif c'était de faire en sorte
que on accompagne une association un
groupement une entreprise privée une
compagnie à devenir h ou à goûter aux
joies de l'émancipation et ça c'est très
important c'est à dire que nous avons un
rôle d'aiguillon
nous avons un rôle de lanceur mais nous
devons toujours ne jamais tomber dans la
ronde des situations parce que sinon
effectivement on n'y arrive pas et on
voit les expériences qui sont conduites
sur les projets et pas simplement sur
des subventions de fonctionnement pour
essayer de pousser un petit peu à ce que
chacun
donne le meilleur de soi même on parlait
de l'investissement et c'est pas un
enjeu majeur non plus que lorsque vous
êtes un territoire et que vous êtes
c'est une thématique qui concerne tout
le territoire national que vous cherchez
à créer de l'emploi sur votre territoire
à développer les entreprises en attirer
d'autres
votre offre culturelle est aujourd'hui
un des indicateurs qui sont scrutés par
les chefs d'entreprise qui décide de
s'installer c'est pas le seul mais là
l'offre culturelle aujourd'hui est un
enjeu absolument essentiel donc quand on
veut développer l'offre culturelle
on sait aussi qu'on travaille pour le
bien-être de l'économie directement
indépendamment des retombées que
génèrent les événements qu'on va créer
et c'est aujourd'hui une corde
indispensable dans l'arc des
collectivités qui veulent attirer des
entreprises et enfin à titre
d'illustration la culture est aussi un
investissement
on en avait pris l'exemple tout à
l'heure avec charte sur une question
juste de déplacement d'agenda d'un
événement régulier
on voit bien les incidences absolue que
ça sur notamment le secteur commerçant
quand vous êtes sur la question des
centres villes c'est déterminant c'est
déterminant donc on voit à quel point
ces questions sont absolument sensible
et et que ça va nous emmener tatiana
notre quatrième partie sur les enjeux et
qu' on ne peut pas modifier ses
équilibres sans prendre beaucoup de
risques peut-être qu'on peut aborder le
troisième point c'est à dire la culture
vous avez repris c'est bon d'accord la
culture comme facteur d'aménagement du
territoire
oui c'est un petit peu ce que je veux
parler du patrimoine aussi séparé du
patrimoine également oui c'est ce que je
disais un petit peu tout à l'heure ça
fait partie de l'attractivité d'un
territoire
donc c'est important et c'est vrai que
les collectivités investissent beaucoup
dans les équipements phares que sont les
théâtres que sont les théâtres les
conservateurs de ce que tout ce que vous
connaissez bien évidemment sur leur
propre territoire
après dire qu'il ya une économie sur ces
équipements n'ont bien sûr c'est vrai
que c'est un coup mais c'est un choix
c'est un choix c'est important de c'est
important pour la population tout le
monde doit pouvoir y accéder et on fait
en sorte que ça se passe comme ça donc
une fois que ces territoires sont
équipés et rayonne cela participe de
l'attractivité et puis et puis nous
avons tout le patrimoine dans sur nos
territoires qu'il faut pouvoir également
entretenir bon ça c'est un petit peu
parfois compliqué mais souvent ce sont
des équipements culturels qui les
occupent
ça c'est un constat aussi et ça ça fera
peut-être partie après des plus tôt des
propositions pour pouvoir aider encore à
conserver ce patrimoine qui fait la
fierté de la france
mais faut-il encore pouvoir l'entretenir
et donner les moyens que ce soit paul et
d'ailleurs pour les propriétaires privés
ou publics de pouvoir les entretenir
merci alors effectivement on en arrive
maintenant à la question des à des
enjeux on a en acier brossé un portrait
il nous semble aujourd'hui que il ya un
véritable risque sur l'enjeu des
collectivités territoriales si l'état et
c'est essentiellement d'état dont on va
parler maintenant les décisions
nationales
si l'état ne ne considère pas qu'il a un
rôle de support absolument nécessaire on
sait que l'état porte un quart des
dépenses de la politique culturelle
française
je dis bien je rappelle que les trois
autres quarts sont portés par les
collectivités territoriales
mais toute décision de l'état a des
répercussions immédiates sur les
politiques qui sont menées à l'échelle
de nos collectivités
on a pris un exemple tout à l'heure on
parlait du patrimoine à l'instant et on
a eu un temps d'échangés assez
intéressant sur le patrimoine privé qui
est un vrai enjeu et pour lesquels les
propriétaires sont souvent écrasés de
charges bien loin de l'image
caricaturale que le propriétaire du
château serait forcément l'homme le plus
riche du de la région cette image là
elle a peut-être existé avant la
révolution française elle s'est
peut-être prolongé dans certains cas on
sait très bien qu'elle est complètement
fausse mais le château
ne doit pas être l'arbre qui cache la
forêt on a aussi des patrimoines
beaucoup plus modeste privé qui risque
d'être frappée
on a pris l'exemple de la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation avec le risque que
collet qui les collectivités ne pouvant
désormais plus agir sur ce levier là se
reportent sur les taxes foncières et
avec les conséquences absolument
dramatiques que ça peut poser pour les
propriétaires privés qui sont déjà serré
à la gorge dès lors qu'il faut il on
voit la perspective en suant à grosses
gouttes refaire une toiture qui va leur
coûter des centaines de milliers d'euros
donc on voit bien à quel point
aujourd'hui les enjeux de l'état
notamment en matière fiscale peut avoir
des conséquences absolument dramatiques
sur l'entretien du patrimoine
c'est vrai aussi vis-à-vis des
entreprises
le mas le mécénat d'art n'est plus aussi
fao temps favorisé qu'il a été par le
passé nous souhaitons dans un projet
présidentiel à venir que les
républicains puissent s'engager sur ce
sujet là nous avons besoin des
entreprises nous collectivités mêmes
acteurs privés de la culture qui soit en
mesure aujourd'hui de valoriser leur
image en soutenant des projets or pour
ça il faut un soutien de l'état est
totalement faux soutien fiscal à travers
des dispositifs beaucoup plus incitatif
que ce peut-être en retrouve en tout cas
ceux qui ont existé et qui ont été
largement raboter ces dernières années
en la matière enfin nous sommes
résolument favorable à la
décentralisation culturelle les
républicains défendent les enjeux de
décentralisation culturelle
si nous voulons que les retombées
économiques de des politiques
culturelles que nous menons soit
toujours aussi forte pour nos
territoires
il faut que l'état nous donne les moyens
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la logique
à partir du moment où nous assumons
trois quarts des dépenses culturelles en
france
l'état ne peut pas se désintéresser des
conséquences de ses propres décisions
quand il réduit nos subventions quand il
redit nos dotations comme l'a fait
allègrement monsieur hollande en 2013
il entraîne des conséquences directes
sur la marche des collectivités qui
parfois
parce qu'il ya des charges fixes à
laquelle elles ne peuvent échapper vont
trouver dans les dépenses culturelles
une variable d'ajustement
et c'est là qu'est le danger quand on
vous dit que sur certains exemples pas
forcément sur tous en euros investis va
générer 10 euros de chiffre d'affaires
en périphérie vous voyez bien les
conséquences que peuvent avoir des
situations dans lesquelles les
collectivités parce qu'elles sont serré
à la gorge par un état qui soit voudrait
les réduire à rien parce que on a évoqué
cette question de la technostructure de
bercy sur cette vision absolument
détestable qui consiste à penser qu'il
ya beaucoup trop de niveaux de
collectivités en tout cas beaucoup trop
de collectivités tout court en france ça
n'est pas connaître la réalité de
l'investissement des départements des
régions des communes et des groupements
de communes sur le territoire notamment
lorsqu'il s'agit on a parlé des
expériences départementale d'aller
porter la culture dans toutes les
communes d'un département ou dans une
partie des communes aux départements qui
est elle-même n'ont pas le moyen de
financer une compagnie est de proposer
cette offre culturelle et ça ça nous
paraît absolument essentiel donc ce
qu'on voudrait simplement dire c'est que
dans le projet des républicains il
apparaît essentiel je pense qu on le
fait en tout cas quand on organise une
séquence comme celle d'aujourd'hui
la culture est un bien indispensable
elle est une préoccupation majeure des
républicains et l'état dans les
décisions qu'il prend notamment
vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales ne peut pas méconnaître
les conséquences terribles que notamment
une baisse des dotations peut avoir sur
les budgets de la culture et donc sur
l'économie en général
voilà un petit peu ce sont quelques
pistes il y en a encore plein d'autres
qu'on pourra imaginer mais en tout cas
c'est le résultat pour pas être trop
long c'est le résultat des échanges que
nous avons eus pendant une heure et
demie je dis bien échange passionnant
qu'il s'agira je pense de poursuivre
dans l'avenir
et maintenant merci c'est très aimable
on est il nous reste combien de temps
combien cinq minutes
donc commençons tout de suite par la
dixième question comme ça on en a pris
plein est ce que quelqu'un souhaite
intervenir
ou est-ce qu'on a été assez clair ou pas
assez justement pour cerner un certain
nombre d'enjeux
ça vous va bon alors on va laisser notre
ravasi christian surget apporter un
témoignage pour illustrer les propos que
vous avez tenus
l'un et l'autre on parle toujours bien
de ce qu'on connaît bien je vous parlais
de ce que j'ai fait il ya vingt ans à
provins on avait des spectacles avec des
rapaces en vol libre au dessus des au
dessus des remparts on travaillait avec
une société d intermittents du spectacle
qui venaient faire un spectacle tous les
tous les week-ends de cela on l'a
transformé complètement en entreprise
privée c'est-à-dire que les
intermittents venaient nous voir et on
est dans cette relation qu'on connaît
bien dans les villes les intermittents
avait le sentiment d'être d'être
sous-payés pour l'activité qu'ils
rendaient et nous à la ville on avait
plutôt le sentiment de payer cher pour
le rendu c'était bon on connaît tout
cela est donc la proposition que
j'aurais fait à l'époque c'est de dire
écoutez mais monter une entreprise en la
ville mais vous met à disposition le
site
donc on met à disposition le site mais
vous créez votre propre entreprise
entreprises privées qu'ils ont monté
aujourd'hui on a deux spectacles comme
ceux là qui fonctionne un avec 200
rapaces en vol libre au dessus des
remparts et l'autre avec le tournoi de
chevalerie
les deux entreprises ce sont maintenant
deux pme qui ont une vingtaine de cdi et
très concrètement quand on parlait de
création d'emplois alors qu'on était
avec trois quatre personnes qui venaient
de faire une prestation le week-end là
il travaille toute l'année on fait une
coupure en gros on démarre de pâques
jusqu'au 11 novembre c'est ça la saison
en année sans qu vide
mais mais très concrètement c'est une
quarantaine d'emplois en cdi qui ont été
créées de cette manière là l'autre
élément c'est que quand on
l'investissement c'est de
l'investissement de long terme là je
parle sur le patrimoine ce que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure là aussi je
prends un exemple que je connais bien
celui de ma ville pendant 20 ans on a
investi et mon successeur continue sur
la même sur la même ligne aujourd'hui on
investit 20 % du budget d'investissement
de la ville uniquement sur le patrimoine
et concrètement ça permet en ce moment
avec la restauration des remparts avec
tout ce que l'on a pu faire d'avoir pour
une nuit une ville de 13 mille habitants
un million deux cent mille visiteurs par
an en année normale mais parce que on a
soigné ce patrimoine et c'était très
long mais aujourd'hui il ya
effectivement une création d'activité
alors les si je prend l'ensemble des
emplois qui dépendent directement de
l'activité touristique mais qui nous est
très culturelle à provins on n'y vient
pas pour la plage pouvoir levier pierre
faire des casses de patrimoine etc
un million deux cent mille visiteurs les
retombées concrètes c'est la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie estime à 600
emplois directs qui dépendent de
l'activité touristique sur une petite
ville voilà quelques exemples concrets
de ce que l'on fait avec une politique
culturelle qui est qui et qui est
conduite et qu'on n'a pu faire parce que
au-delà de la ville l'état bien entendu
nous a aidé pour la restauration mais
sans le département et la région et sans
le fait de 20% du budget
d'investissement
d'où l'idée alors je sais pas si c'est
la taxe d'habitation autre chose vois ce
que je sais c'est qu'il faut une recette
autonomes parce que à chaque fois débat
budgétaire quand on explique à nos
concitoyens comme et 20% sur le
patrimoine vous avez qui dit oui mais ça
sert à quoi etc
est ce que c'est bien utile de refaire
ça la réalité aujourd'hui plus personne
sous la pause merci de la prochaine fois
on invitera notre groupe de travail
parce que c'est vrai que provins est
assez exemplaire quand même en la
matière
avec les investissements qui ont été
comme charte et comme chalon et comme
tous les autres par les investissements
qui ont été menées voilà merci en tout
cas de votre attention et nous passons à
la parole au groupe dany genevard
je rapporte
nous avions à nous avions à réfléchir à
la question de 2,2 du lien avec la
création les créateurs les initiatives
de création et de promotion culturelle
alors le premier constat que j'aurais
faire c'est que cette extraordinaire
nous avions un peu plus d'une dizaine de
d'adjoint
responsable de la culture au niveau
régional au niveau municipal et c'est
formidable parce que la parole a jailli
les exemples se sont multipliées la
passion la passion de parler de sa ville
de son action culturelle sont là et ça
c'est le premier constat que j'aurais
faire le deuxième constat c'est que il y
a manifestement chez tous les
intervenants mais tous ceux qui sont là
aujourd'hui et probablement beaucoup de
ceux qui nous écoutent
il n'y a pas d'action culturelle sans
volonté politique et la volonté
politique c'est le moteur de l'action
culturelle le 2 c'est l'un des deux
moteurs le deuxième moteur c'est le
budget puisque le budget et la
manifestation de la volonté politique et
donc
vous mêler à tout ça l'imagination
l'inventivité
vous avez des choses formidables qui se
font sur les territoires et je crois
cher christian qu'on ne s'est pas trompé
en venant faire en faisant venir ici des
acteurs à part entière de l'action
culturelle que sont les élus à la
culture
alors nous avons à la première question
comment avez vous fait de votre
territoire un lieu de création
culturelle on a évoqué la volonté on a
évoqué le budget et on a évoqué les
lieux de culture les équipements
culturels et c'est sur cette première
séquence je crois que madame granvorka
vous allez intervenir
oui merci beaucoup de me donner la
parole bonjour à tous bonsoir a tous
voila d'accord merci président voilà
donc oui effectivement moi je vais
parler des lieux culturels et bien
définir que lorsqu'on parle des lieux
culturels ont par des lieux intérieurs
mais aussi des hors les murs voilà c'est
important et comme vous l'avez dit tout
part de la volonté politique des
collectivités déjà de deux l'accent
qu'elle souhaite mettre sur ces
différents lieux culturels du budget
alloué comme vous l'avait dit et comme
monsieur le président et les autres
intervenants l'ont dit la nécessité de
la décentralisation pour nous un qui
nous paraît importante pour les
retombées tout à la fois touristique et
tout ce qui se rapporte à l'emploi nous
avons parlé aussi des des équipements
physiques et des matériels qui
pourraient mettre être mise en
visibilité
d'ailleurs nous sommes posé la question
est ce que le fait d'avoir beaucoup
d'équipements culturels dans sa vie est
un plus donc là on y répondra sûrement
ensemble et vous aviez nous avions tous
parlé aussi de la nécessité d'avoir un
réseau soutenu pour garder le dynamisme
de
de toute cette de toute cette activité
culturelle culturelle dans la ville
nous avons parlé aussi de la nécessité
d'avoir une programmation attractive et
qui dit attractif dit aussi une
programmation de qualité et je pense que
ça va beaucoup alimenté aussi les des
peuples et des bas qui vont suivre
nous avons aussi vu qu'il était
important d'avoir un service culturel
solide pour pouvoir porter justement
cette politique culturelle dans la ville
et nous avons nous avons été portés de
nous interroger sur le sur le rapport
sur le relationnel entre les
associations et la collectivité les
associations et les habitants pour
pouvoir justement faire vivre ce toute
cette programmation culturelle
nous avons aussi parlé de la nécessité
de garder la maîtrise des différents
équipements culturels
nous avons de ce fait aborder par fois
les problématiques que nous puissions
havre que nous pourrions avoir avec les
scènes nationales non pas que nous
soyons contre les scènes nationales mais
pour certaines elles elles pourraient un
petit peu échappé justement dans le
fonctionnement de leurs rapports avec la
ville
donc nous avions abordé la nécessité de
l'importance du département et de la
région pour cette politique culturelle
de bon ah bon et nous avions aussi
abordé la question de s que la gratuité
systématique permettait la promotion de
la culture
voilà merci pour ma part merci alors sur
cette question des lieux de culture nous
avons
dit que le lieu de culture c'est à la
fois la vitrine de l'action culturelle
pour la population
mais c'est aussi à l'égard des créateurs
un signe de respect autrefois on
accueillait les les artistes des fois
dans des structures qui n'était pas
totalement approprié un lieu dédié à une
pratique culturelle un lieu conçu pour
une pratique culturelle
c'est une forme de respect à l'égard de
la création culturelle et ça ne peut
qu'encourager la qualité de la
production culturelle et donc le respect
du spectateur
ça c'est la première chose nous avons
aussi je voudrais revenir sur la
question de la programmation on a parlé
beaucoup des relations avec la drac
ça rejoint la question qui a été évoqué
dans l'aisne de l'atelier numéro un en
expliquant qu' on ne peut pas imaginer
un système où la drac et dans la
l'injonction culturel vous devez faire
comme si vous devez faire comme ça et
que la ville qui est le financeur n'ai
aucune liberté en la matière ce qui veut
pas dire qu en veillant toutefois à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas une culture savante
promu par la drac et une culture
populaire promu par la ville
simplement il faut que ces conceptions
là se fécondent mutuellement ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas
on a souvent des injonctions en eux
notamment quand les scènes sont
labellisés qui laisse peu de qui laisse
peu de liberté aux collectivités et
c'est madame le maire de deux adjoints
de pontoise qui nous donne un exemple
intéressant lorsque les scènes ont été
labellisées dans la ville de pontoise
les pontoisiens ne s'y sont plus
reconnus et on a vu arriver une
clientèle beaucoup plus extérieur parce
que on rétablissait le clivage
finalement entre
les formes de culture élitiste et une
forme de culture populaire mais
attention quand je vous dis ça ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas amener
toute la population à des pratiques plus
exigeante mais tout ça doit se faire
dans un dosage savant et en ayant une
bonne connaissance de sa population
c'est pour ça que les villes les
collectivités locales et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
demeurer des acteurs à part entière et
ne pas sous traiter totalement les
politiques culturelles à l'état ou à des
structures totalement indépendante
d'elle-même donc c'est dans cet
équilibre bien compris qu'il faut
rechercher la promotion de la culture
moi j'ai fait ça pendant des années dans
ma ville et je sais que une fois que le
public est en confiance il vient il fait
confiance à la programmation
il se pose pas de question le programme
de la saison culturelle de culture elle
arrive et il prend son abonnement parce
qu'il sait que on le respectera et qu'on
lui proposera des choses de qualité et
ça se travaille là il est long ce
travail d'imprégnation il est long et
c'est pas des coûts culturel c'est pas
des one shot la culture c'est une
appréciation sont des politiques de long
terme qui respecte à la fois le créateur
et le public et et nous élus nous sommes
les médiateurs entre les créateurs et le
public en tout cas moi c'est la
conception que j'ai entendu cet après
midi de la part des acteurs culturels
sur encore un point sur les pratiques
amateurs que princesse a évoqué vous
avez un joli prénom - ça impose le
respect donc sur les pratiques amateurs
et les pratiques professionnelles
nous avons déterminé que c'était quelque
chose qui pouvait se féconder
mutuellement et je crois que c'est
monsieur le député d'alsace qui disent
et que il avait calculé que dans lorsque
les professionnels en matière de musique
d'apprentissage de la musique venait
dans les associations
eh bien c'était l'équivalent de 300
équivalents temps plein sur ton
territoire
l'équivalent de 300 équivalents temps
pleins de travail professionnel mais qui
vient herrig et les pratiques amateurs
donc il n'y a pas d'un côté les
pratiques amateurs et les pratiques
professionnelles tous ces deux mondes là
peuvent se féconder voilà donc ça c'est
un point que je voulais évoquer et puis
troisième point vous avez dit princesse
les pratiques dans les lieux et hors les
murs on a vu que pour aller à la
rencontre pour que les artistes les
créateurs aille à la rencontre du public
on peut exploiter les lieux publics mais
les lieux extérieurs publics et tout
peut devenir support de création ce sont
des oeuvres d'art dans là ville ce sont
des photographies exposées sur les
grilles d'un établissement
ce sont des jardins publics qui peuvent
devenir des petits lieux de
représentations enfin bref il y a
matière à c'est aussi une façon de faire
tomber la prévention qui peut exister
pour certains qui sont dans
l'intimidation que peut susciter le lieu
de culture et c'est aussi un moyen de
faire se rencontrer les créateurs et le
public
voilà je passe la parole maintenant
madame le maire adjoint de saint quentin
qui va nous parler à la fois des des
actions spécifiques pour associer les
artistes ou des marches le développement
de l'offre culturelle et la
sensibilisation à la culture
donc madame le maire adjoint de saint
quentin
madame marie laurence m marie-laurence
c'est à vous merci merci beaucoup
bonjour à tous il ya une chose
essentielle et keith qui servira de
dénominateur commun entre
ce que je vais vous présenter il s'agit
en fait de l'action culturelle puisque
si nous nous accordons tous à dire que
il est essentiel nous avons un
équipement culturel et bien c'est ça va
être tout ce que nous allons bâtir à
partir de à la fois de nos équipements
culturels et en lien avec la population
s'il est une chose essentielle c'est que
nous allons aller au devant de cette
population
comment procéder et bien tout simplement
déjà en j'allais dire quadrillant la
ville ou le lieu où nous sommes de
manière à sortir des lieux dits
culturels pour aller investir d'autres
lieux alors en effet cela peut-être dans
les maisons de quartier
cela peut-être en extérieur à ninon l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure et cela peut être
également alors sous différentes formes
en extérieur et aussi au pied des
immeubles
tout dépend de la configuration
évidemment delà de la collectivité dans
laquelle nous nous ouvrons ça c'est
absolument essentiel alors bien sûr il y
a je vais pas vous dresser une liste
exhaustive des exemples qui sont mis en
place
on s'appuie tous énormément sur les
résidences d'artistes
elles sont essentielles à la meilleure
connaissance et au développement de la
culture
s'il ya une chose aussi à laquelle nous
travaillons tous au travers de l'action
culturelle que nous mettons en place
c'est justement de casser cette notion
élitiste à rattacher à la culture
et pour ce faire et bien avec la
résidence d'artistes on peut travailler
au travers de alors exemple bords de
seine
art d'être spectateur ce sont des petits
exemples d'actions qui vont permettre à
d oui alors pardon parce que je vais
m'appuyer sur un exemple que je connais
bien qui est à bord au jeu doute un
exemple que je connais bien puisque
c'est ce que nous avons mis en place à
saint quentin notamment alors l'art
d'être spectateur c'est tout simplement
le metteur en scène donc d'une des
compagnies qui est en résidence qui va
rencontrer préalablement avant la pièce
un petit groupe de personnes néophytes
pour leur présenter cette pièce leur
expliquer ce qu'ils vont voir recueillir
leurs impressions
le bord de seine c'est ce qu'il va c'est
ce qui va découler
après le spectacle où justement
concrètement le l'artiste où les
artistes vont s'asseoir sur la scène où
on éventuellement vous rencontrer le
public dans une autre salle pour pouvoir
échanger avec lui sur leurs impressions
et leur montrer que eux aussi peuvent
très bien devenir acteur parce que c'est
là tout l'intérêt de la chose quand on
parle de de mettre en place du théâtre
du spectacle vivant
un petit peu partout et bien c'est aussi
d'amener les gens au spectacle vivant
peut-être aussi de susciter des
vocations alors ça a été abordée
notamment et pardon parce que c'est un
point qui a subi qui a suscité quelques
controverses
puisque notamment auprès de notre ami de
députés d'alsace on parlait de demos de
ces orchestres qui sont mis en place
avec des enfants des différents
quartiers et qui réunissent des
professionnels de la musique mais bien
au delà des mots c'est un simple exemple
il peut y avoir d'autres actions comme
par exemple les classes orchestres qui
peuvent se mettre en place
justement en milieu scolaire alors
parlons-en
comment nous allons développer cette
offre
eh bien nous allons développer cette
offre en nous appuyant fortement sur
notre j'allais dire travail auprès de
l'éducation nationale en effet nous
intervenons tous en collège en école
primaire et ce global mans de manière de
manière assez récurrente et des actions
y compris même dès j'allais dire des
pans entiers d'une saison culturelle ont
pu être présentées une ville à donner
cet exemple ont pu être présentées dans
les différents établissements scolaires
ce qui est important aussi au delà du
scolaire c'est de promouvoir les
pratiques familiales parce que nous
déplorions tous le fait de voir des
équipements culturels fermé le week end
ou pardon fermée pendant les vacances
scolaires
ce qui importe justement c'est de créer
une offre pendant les vacances scolaires
ou plus exactement de créer une action
que ce soit dans nos musées ou dans nos
galeries d'art qui vont nous permettre
d'amener un public très généraliste
alors les musées les galeries d'art
on peut également les sortir de leur
lieu dit en allant
créée en créant tout simplement et
madame annie l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
des expositions hors les murs sur des
grilles elles vont être sur des totems
métalliques
elles vont se répartir à différents
endroits de la ville elles peuvent être
aussi inhérentes et se mettre à
disposition de tout un chacun qui
souhaitent l'emprunter justement pour en
profiter c'est également ce que vont
faire les musées qui vont également
créer ce que l'on appelle des dix bons
et ça va être des reproductions si vous
voulez des oeuvres dites du musée et le
médiateur va aller en ehpad
par exemple pour présenter le musée
présentait une une nouvelle exposition
donc autant d'éléments qui vont nous
permettre d'associer à la fois les
artistes et au public en même temps de
développer la culture parce que encore
une fois ça n'est pas une question
d'élitisme parce que nous avons un rôle
essentiel à jouer en matière d'éducation
est donc d'amener les publics à y
adhérer
alors il ya aussi plein d'autres moyens
par cela à travers cela en faisant
travailler des jeunes justement autour
de la promotion du patrimoine pour
mettre en place avec des vidéos et bien
d
des vidéos explicatives dudit lieu
et c est là en faisant travailler ces
jeunes ils s'approprient le lieu
voilà ce sont autant d'exemples qui vont
nous permettre donc de développer la
culture d'associer les artistes au
public et enfin de couvrir j'allais dire
un une ville dans son intégralité d'être
le plus large possible
merci merci beaucoup donc je relèverai
quelques points notables dans les propos
qui viennent d'être retenus c'est
d'abord parce qu'il m'a frappé dans tout
ce que vous avez dit c'est la très
grande inventivité pour ça que je vous
ai demandé de nous développer bords de
seine et l'art d'être spectateur parce
que je trouve que c'est vraiment
intéressant
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on donne
dans les politiques culturelles de la
visibilité aux créateurs ce que souvent
on a vu l'oeuvre est pas le créateur
or de plus en plus les politiques
culturelles mettant avant les créateurs
mettent en avant les artistes ont fait
parler les auteurs ont fait de dessiner
les illustrateurs sous l'oeil ébahi des
enfants dans les fêtes du livre les
salons du livre ont fait parler les uns
les acteurs de la façon dont ils ont
conçu leur rôle et que ce que signifient
leur personnage on fait venir des
metteurs en scène pour présenter leur
film ça je trouve que c'est une tendance
qui est
importante et qu'il faut cultiver parce
que et particulièrement en ce moment
nos créateurs nos artistes souffrent
tellement il faudra que nous réparions
aussi pour eux le lien que nous avons
avec eux dans les politiques que nous
allons mettre en oeuvre il faudra pas
les oublier parce qu'ils ont été très
très malmenées par la crise sanitaire
la deuxième remarque que je voudrais
faire c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
d'imagination dans tout ce que vous avez
dit énormément d'imagination il ya une
jeune adjointe à la culture qui nous a
dit qu'elle avait hérité dans son vient
d'arriver dans son conseil municipal
d'un équipement mais je sais pas si elle
est encore là je ne la vois plus d'un
équipement qui permet de ce j'ai pas
retenu le nom de cet équipement micro
folie voila voila et donc les micros
follis ça permet de visualiser en 3d a
lieu culturel
donc je pense que le numérique est un
champ important que nous n'avons pas
encore complètement explorer comme comme
support de lien avec la culture
on a évoqué également sur la question du
lien avec le jeune public parce que moi
c'est un point qui me paraît extrêmement
important moi j'ai mis en place un
partenariat culturel avec eux les écoles
qui a fonctionné qui fonctionne encore
formidablement bien
j'ai été satisfait de voir que ça se
passait bien que l'éducation nationale
parce que c'est pas si facile que ça
hein c'est pas si facile que ça de
collaborer avec l'éducation nationale
qui est très jalouse de son pré carré
qui n'aiment pas beaucoup qu'on vient de
mettre le nez dans ses affaires
donc là encore beaucoup de choses on est
sont faites avec l'éducation nationale
en matière d'éveil du jeune public que
c'est plutôt quelque chose d'intéressant
vous avez mentionné dans la politique du
livre le lien avec bien sûr les écoles
avec
les ehpad les seniors on va dire les
seniors vous avez aussi évoqué le lien
l'éveil à la culture de la toute petite
enfance dès la crèche on peut éveiller
les enfants à l'art contemporain à la
lecture bien sûr odessa l'illustration
mais il ya beaucoup de choses parce que
les enfants c c'est un public qui mérite
le meilleur pour ça qu'il faut pas
donner n'importe quoi aux très jeunes
enfants mais qui découvre les choses
sans prévention par exemple vous mettez
des tableaux d'art contemporain dans des
enfants de très jeunes enfants
ils réagissent immédiatement sans
prévention sont toutes les préventions
que nous pouvons parfois avoir à l'égard
de l'art contemporain
une expérience intéressante aussi qui a
été évoquée eloquentia les concours
d'éloquence entre des jeunes et avec des
comédiens sont des choses enfin tout ça
pour vous dire que il se fait mille et
une choses sur nos territoires et avec
un immense respect à la fois pour les
créateurs et à la fois pour le public et
je redis pour moi le l'élu il est ce
passeur entre le créateur et le public
et c'est un noble rôle qui nous est
dévolue
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près tenu
le temps et je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
jean-philippe vous voulez que je mets
devant c'est donc voilà on voit trop
souvent non moi ce que je trouve ce que
j'ai trouvé intéressant dans votre
propos c'est que c'est chez nous c'est
chez les républicains
qu'on parle des résidences d'artistes
j'ai pas si vous imaginez le chemin
qu'on a parcouru en 20 ou 30 ans c'est
dans notre famille dans notre maison
qu'on explique que c'est la place des
artistes dans les territoires qui est
essentiel
trois élus venus de territoire
complètement différent parle ici de la
place des artistes
et explique que finalement ce qui est
essentiel dans une politique culturelle
c'est d'abord on doit avoir des artistes
parce que ça commence par là parce qu'il
n'ya pas de culture sans art et que nous
on ne l'a pas oublié et je pense que
c'est un vrai marqueur parce que non
c'est pas une idéologie non avec en tout
cas c'est un principe c'est un principe
et c'est chez nous que ça se passe et
j'aimerais bien que l'ensemble du monde
de l'art l'entendent
parce que c'est ce qu'on fait dans nos
collectivités concrètement c'est ce que
nous faisons tous et ça c'est très
différent et je voudrais tout le monde
prenne la mesure du basculement de notre
famille on n'est pas à dire on doit
avoir juste une fonction publique en
charge de la culture
mais que d'abord on part des artistes et
j'insiste là dessus parce que c'est
vraiment il me semble un vrai marqueur
une vraie différence
et pourquoi on a cette marque parce
qu'on est des gens de droite et des
centres et nous on croit à la création
et à la liberté de l'individu est ce que
vous croyez qu'il ya un autre endroit où
la création ne se retrouve qu'à travers
la liberté de l'individu et la liberté
c'est la création c'est que nous on
encadre pas je pense qu'aucun d'entre
nous on n'a jamais demandé à un artiste
sa carte ni sa couleur on lui a même pas
forcément demandé de réussir mais
simplement on lui demande de créer parce
que ça ses notes matrix on est des
créateurs on est des développeurs et
vous venez surtout des gens de liberté
et je pense qu'il faut toujours qu'on
reparte de ce qu'on est au début parce
qu'il peut pas y avoir de politique
culturelle
si on oublie ce qu'on est d'abord et je
te remercie d'avoir vraiment mis là
l'accent sur la place des artistes et
des uns les autres sur sur les
résidences c'est vraiment un vrai
marqueur
[Applaudissements]
pour la caméra j'ai surtout vous avez
dit qu'ils étaient très très intéressant
c'est que on peut inventer un certain
nombre de projets sans forcément que ce
soit très coûteux départ des deux
projets parce qu'il faut pas rêver non
plus le jour si l'on prend de pouvoir
que je souhaite à prochaine fois la
situation de l'etat sera très dur
financière mondiale à tête c'est parce
que l'état pourra faire aujourd'hui dans
les départements moi je suis élu dans un
département
c'est de plus en plus difficile le rsa
dix mineurs abandonnés c'est une
situation très très difficile
donc c'est pour ça que faut pas
s'attendre non plus à des merveilles est
par contre il faut effectivement essayé
de trouver des projets de proximité des
choses vous avez évoqué après très bien
sûr la question louis juste très court
sur la question des budgets moins je
sais quand je suis arrivé comme adjointe
à la culture
la première question qui est posée c'est
celle des budgets mais il peut pas avoir
d'action culturelle sans budget il peut
pas y avoir d'action culturelle sans
budget mais c'est pas forcément des
budgets dément donc on ne peut pas
réduire la culture ou aux budgets qui
lui sont consacrés c'est important mais
c'est pas le seul le seul prisme par
lequel il faut aborder la culture je
cède la parole à ma collègue agnès très
vite pour rebondir aussi sur ce que sur
ce que disait annie sur la pratique
amateur je crois que c'est un des
éléments qui me qui me semble important
est un marqueur pour nous aussi
christian c'est que derrière la liberté
de créer on a aussi la liberté pour
chacun d'être artiste et ne sont pas
artistes que ceux qui vivent du fait
d'être artiste et je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
pour nous important aussi c'est que
chacun peut l'être
chacun peut créer chacun peut participer
à la vie culturelle est souvent un
marqueur avec avec une vision élitiste
une vision de la gauche de la culture où
on cherche à expliquer qu'ils pensent
bien qu'ils créent bien créé un vent de
biens et les autres eh bien je pense que
quand on est à droite on pense que
chacun peut créer les amateurs les
professionnels amateurs ça veut pas dire
faire mal
amateurs ça veut dire faire à côté faire
à sa façon et je crois que c'est un bon
moyen d'accéder à la culture que de
passer par la pratique et je crois que
c'est que ça c'est un marqueur de la
droite sur les sujets culturels
voilà merci merci à toi alors pour notre
table-ronde la culture comme vecteur de
cohésion sociale et nationale j'appelle
à mes côtés didier leprince qui est
maire de fontvannes conseil
départemental de l'eau vice président en
charge de la culture et qui nous parlera
de la médiathèque jacques chirac de 3 et
jean philippe lefebvre qui est donc
adjoint maire de dole conseiller
régional et président vous l'avez bien
compris la fédération nationale ancien
président de la fédération nationale des
collectivités pour la culture la fncc
alors donc le le thème de notre échange
j'enlève mon masque et est d'une
actualité brûlante puisque comme je vous
le disais
s'agit donc de la culture comme vecteur
de cohésion sociale et nationale
et c'est vrai que le panel des élus
qu'on a uni était extrêmement
représentative de la diversité des
territoires je tiens à le souligner
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
absolument passionnante donc des élus de
l'aube du jura de la loire du val d'oise
de seine-saint-denis de la vienne et
c'était vraiment des échanges d'autant
plus intéressant que comme je le
rappelle il faut bien retenir ce chiffre
qui a été dit en amont par notre
président christian jacob c'est que 73 %
des dépenses sont effectuées par les
collectivités territoriales et
malheureusement quand on a mis la
culture sous cloche
ces collectivités n'ont pas eu voix au
chapitre en tout cas ce qui est ressorti
de nos discussions c'est que face à une
société profondément inquiète et
meurtrie par la crise sanitaire et
économique fracturé également il faut le
dire par leasing et les inégalités
sociales et territoriales et donc en
proie à l'exclusion et aux extrémismes
nous sommes absolument convaincus nous
en avons en tout cas nous sommes arrivés
à ce consensus mais ça paraît même
universel que la culture est un remède
et donc nous avons essayé de répondre à
ces trois questions et nous allons donc
vous faire un compte rendu
d'abord la première question était de
savoir comment est ce que nous pourrions
au plus près du terrain lutter contre
les inégalités d'accès à la culture est
développée donc l'accès à la culture
dans les zones sous dotées en
équipements culturels et en offre
culturelle parce que on l'a vu à la
région ile-de-france à notre arrivée on
s'était rendu compte que 50 % des
subventions avaient été fléché à paris
et la seine saint denis alors qu'il ya
déjà une hyper concentration de toutes
les activités et des équipements
culturels à paris est donc la grande
couronne et est la grande oubliée de la
politique culturelle de l'île de france
donc ça c'était la première question
comment lutter contre les inégalités
d'accès la deuxième comment est-ce que
les initiatives culturelles de terrain
permettent de lutter contre l'exclusion
est ce à ce point de vue là tout ton
témoignage sur la médiathèque jacques
chirac était absolument passionnant et
enfin comment donc à travers la culture
renforcer les liens sociaux
sentiment d'appartenance à la nation
notre héritage commun et les valeurs
communes de la république voilà donc je
donne la parole dans un premier temps à
jean philippe qui va donc nous retracer
un peu tout ce qui a été dit et ensuite
et ensuite vous ne m'en voudrez pas
parce qu'après il faut que je reprenne
mon train pour rentrer à dole c'est pour
ça que je te passe là bas
voilà non d'abord effectivement il y
avait une vraie diversité d'élus et donc
aussi des vrais diversité je vais pas
dire de souffrance mais puisque c'était
quand même à l'origine de notre de notre
atelier et la culture comme vecteur de
cohésion sociale et nationale tu l'as
dit d'abord un certain nombre de maires
ont fait part des grandes des
difficultés aujourd'hui de 2,2 du tissu
social de leur ville et les uns et les
autres je pense par exemple notamment à
des initiatives qui ont pu être porté
ici à champigny ici au blanc-mesnil ici
à saint-etienne
peu importe puisque tu perdras toi tout
à l'heure de ton de ton projet dans ton
département ont montré que la culture
pouvait être c'est pas un pansement
c'est parce qu'on a dit c'est un élément
consubstantiel d'une politique de ville
et je crois qu'on a tous été attentifs à
utiliser le terme de population
d'ailleurs que d'abord on cible une
population et pas un public un public
c'est très ciblée c'est très connu et ça
c'est bon j'ai souvent l'habitude de
dire que là on arrose là où il pleut
déjà quand on parle de public alors
qu'une population et c'est le rôle c'est
l'enjeu d'un élu c'est de toucher toute
une population
des exemples ont donc été porté sur par
rapport aux outils qui peuvent être à la
disposition des élus je pense à notre
collègue aussi de rambouillet qui est là
moi j'en ai retenu j'ai retenu trois
points donc la première c'est que nous
nous adressons à la population et pas un
public et danse là sa population dans sa
diversité et ses diversités
le second point c'est que tout le monde
a été très attentif mais d'autres
groupes qui ont en ont parlé
c'est que tout commence dans la toute
petite enfance et que l'essentiel passe
évidemment par l'éducation artistique et
culturelle dans le milieu scolaire au
plus tôt et c'est notamment
je pense ça peut être un vrai marqueur
de notre famille peu
éthique que les élus de notre famille
politique s'engage très largement dans
des plans vaste cohérent de d'éducation
artistique et culturelle dans le milieu
scolaire
quel que soit d'ailleurs les territoires
et puis le troisième point est
finalement je rebondis sur ce qui a été
dit c'est que je pense que un des moyens
de cohésion du territoire c'est de
multiplier les résidences notamment des
résidences d'artistes là où elles ne
sont pas et notamment en zone rurale
c'est un très bon moyen d'amener la
culture est d'amener un autre regard
dans les territoires moi j'avais noté
ces trois points qui me semblait
important j'ai j'ai également noté
puisqu'on a aussi le souci de trouver
des pistes pour l'avenir
c'est peut-être de se dire que c'est
peut-être à nous désormais de porter
l'idée je ne sais pas c'était un
secrétariat d'état
ça existait autrefois mais vraiment à la
décentralisation culturelle
c'est à dire que à nous aussi d'avoir
une unité au niveau de l'état pour
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales dans le domaine culturel
ce pourrait être une belle ambition en
tout cas et puis
mais là c'est plus à titre personnel je
pense que on ne risquerait rien en
développement des formations entre élus
à la culture de nos familles politiques
pour échanger et construire aussi une
sorte de sinon un corpus commun mais en
tout cas avoir des idées partagées je
crois que ça nous fait pas de mal on
sent on s'en est rendu compte
voilà mes skis ce qui est certain c'est
que compte tenu du nombre de
collectivités que nous portons dans ce
pays mais ont réussi quoi et dans ce
domaine là on réussit simplement à nous
maintenant peut-être de mieux le mieux
le faire connaître
en tout cas je remercie l'ensemble des
collègues qui ont apporté toute leur
diversité parce que c'était ça qui était
très intéressant je pense et je dis sous
l'oeil de la présidente de notre de
notre équipe toute leur diversité de
deux territoires
merci beaucoup alors c'est vrai qu'on a
pas mal discuté de culture itinérante
est entre guillemets inclusive c'est à
dire que quand les publics
les populations ne peuvent pas se
déplacer à porter la culture pas de
problème merci infiniment cet éclairage
c'est d'amener la culture là où sont
donc les populations et donc vous nous
avez donné un très bel éclairage en tant
que adjoint au maire en charge de la
ville de rambouillet sur les initiatives
des d'itinérance qui permet de
démocratiser l'accès à la culture en
s'adressant donc à tous les publics ce
qui permet aussi de stimuler un discours
d'union et ça c'est extrêmement
important parce que malheureusement
parfois les transports sont un frein
aussi à l'accès à la culture et donc
l'idée c'est d'avoir une culture qu'ils
puissent irriguer le territoire et être
là où on ne l'attend pas j'ai été
extrêmement inspiré par l'exemple du
maire du blanc mesnil qui a organisé un
spectacle de 6000 personnes il avait
commencé à 3000 personnes
un spectacle de musique classique et
petit à petit voilà alors qu'il ya 70 %
de logements sociaux dont les quartiers
environnants
là où a lieu donc cet opéra et il nous
expliquait qu'en fait petit à petit ça a
brassé des populations qui n'avaient
rien à voir les unes avec les autres et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est ce
brassage de population y compris dans
les quartiers défavorisés moi juste j'ai
donné aussi mon expérience de quand
j'étais vice présidente en charge de la
culture c'est très très intéressant
aussi de parler d'éducation artistique
et culturelle pour quelle raison on
avait organisé dans les lycées
professionnels
on avait fait entrer des auteurs dans
les classes et je crois beaucoup est ce
que tu as dit annie c'est la rencontre
avec un artiste la rencontre avec un
auteur l'idée c'était pas faire des
ateliers d'écriture comme on en fait
très souvent dans les lycées non là
c'est est de confronter un auteur une
oeuvre à des élèves parce que quand il
rencontre l'auteur ensuite ça leur donne
envie d'aller découvrir l'oeuvre de
l'auteur et donc moi j'ai expliqué que
l'idée c'est de leur faire comprendre ce
qu'était le travail de création d'un
auteur pourquoi est ce qu'il est animé
par l'envié d'écrire un livre et
c'était très intéressant de voir la
réactivité des élèves qui nous disaient
mais madame nous on pensait que tous les
écrivains il était mort pour eux les
écrivains c'est victor hugo baudelaire
marcel proust et des vieilles choses
possibles ce qu'on retourne dans les
bibliothèques mais pas des corps humain
et quand les auteurs venaient dans les
classes c'était passionnant il avait des
bouquins la main et disaient vous voyez
voilà moi ça m'a construit j'avais ça en
moi et ce qui est aussi étonnant et
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
confronter un auteur à un élève
c'étaient les questions qu'ils
revenaient systématiquement monsieur
c'est quoi la marque de votre voiture
parce que moi je vous connais pas vous
n'êtes pas célèbre vous êtes écrivain
mais si vous étiez intelligent vous
feriez un autre métier vous gagnez pas
d'argent vous n'êtes pas si avec tout ça
pour vous dire que pour ces jeunes
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
c'est pour ça qu'on avait fait en ile de
france
on a tout fait pour qu'elle est lisse
escouade la porte d'entrée vers la
culture pour leur apporter la culture là
où ils sont parce que parfois évidemment
ils n'ont pas les repères et que dans
leur famille a pas cet accès à la
culture et de leur montrer que le
travail de création en soi et bien c'est
rien que ça c'est suffisant pour ils ne
peuvent pas comprendre que ça peut se
suffire à soi même d'avoir envie de
créer pour eux ça doit ou aboutir à de
la célébrité ou et c'est ce que me
disaient les auteurs que c'est très
enrichissant parce qu'en plus il ne se
brident pas dans leurs questions ils ne
s'auto censure pas il pose les questions
comme ils ressentent et donc on a
beaucoup appris et encore une fois je
pense qu'on doit continuer y compris sur
l'art contemporain
on avait fait avec le fera qu'une une
malle itinérantes ou présenter à des
jeunes là aussi deux lycées
professionnels ce qui était une oeuvre
contemporaine alors c'était vraiment
passionnant et donc moi je crois cette
culture inclusive et itinérante qui
permet donc de démocratiser encore plus
l'accès à la culture et tu le disais toi
mais mon cher didier avec la médiathèque
jacques chirac j'ai pas si vous la
connaissez mais il faut absolument aller
voir ses époustouflants ça crée du lien
social
je te laisse parler de cette merci agnès
j'en profite pour saluer christian le
remercier j'ai la chance en tant qu'élu
local de participer au 1 certains forums
aujourd'hui à cette conférence sur la
gueule sur la culture
attention par moments
la culture est pas loin du cultuel mais
on a une grande mission dans notre pays
aussi est aidé en jeu et l'enjeu
culturel
il est à 9,1 alors parlé de la
médiathèque jacques chirac
une anecdote il ya trente ans je me
lance un peu en vie publique et puis
directeur de la culture à 3 à l'époque
je suis un petit élu rural il dit mais
mon pauvre didier mais tu peux pas faire
de culture en vue khalid et a pas les
moyens de compenser difficile et autres
et puis trente ans après françois baroin
me disiez tu seras vice-président la
culture en charge la médiathèque jacques
chirac allait cinéma alors j'ai appelé
mon ami mission qui entraîne maintenant
tu vois le territoire s'agrandit trois
champagnes métropole maintenant intègre
une certaine frange de la ruralité et
dont je découvre un domaine fabuleux et
qui répond à beaucoup de sujets on
évoquait souvent l'éducation agnès tout
à l'heure les deux questions est rendu
très souvent dans le sujet des cultures
alors la médiathèque jacques chirac
c'est un immense un très très beau
bâtiment de verre qui contient des
oeuvres fabuleuse et bien et bien sûr
historique dont celle d'ailleurs écrite
par bernard de clairvaux
alors d'où une volonté fabien sur une
médiathèque attractif
une médiathèque accessible à tous et tu
l'as dit je vais revenir et surtout
aussi un lieu de ressources qui associe
qui permet aux acteurs locaux de de se
rencontrer une posture
tu l'as dit il faut aller chercher aussi
le public hier que faut pas attendre
forcément que l'on vienne la médiathèque
mais grâce à nos réseaux grâce aux
médias d'internet grâce aussi à aux
actions mis en place à l'échelle du
territoire aux animations
on va au plus près donc on va public
faut faire évoluer la médiathèque la
médiathèque aujourd'hui on est souvent
le numérique est revenu on est
d'ailleurs à trois questions
bibliothèque on a le label bio tech mais
riche et donc on a vu notamment pendant
le comité bien pendant le coc vide
le service continuer les équipes se sont
adaptés et on a permis donc grâce au
numérique donc à tous nos abonnés et on
a énormément d'ailleurs augmenter le
taux de fréquentation et d'abonnements
malgré les 2 malgré la fermeture
physique grâce donc au sujet du
numérique
et puis l'essentiel aux 6 et interagir
autres et acteurs locaux
on a beaucoup d'animations qui sont qui
se font à l'intérieur de la médiathèque
avec un certain nombre d'associations
diverses et variées notamment dans le
domaine du handicap
on est en fait on vient se rencontrer on
vient se parler on
à se comprendre à s'écouter on a mis
d'ailleurs dans que je revenais sur
quatre sujets essentiels l'accessibilité
excusez moi de le dire aussi vous êtes à
3 vous n'avez pas de papiers vous êtes
un jeune et meynac comme on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure vous avez accès à la
bibliothèque
il ya la médiathèque jacques chirac vous
avez accès à un certain nombre
d'ouvragés vous pouvez lire le journal
vous pouvez accéder et partager et
échanger et vous pouvez on le voit
souvent aussi rencontré on avait
personne qui venait donc consulter les
ouvrages et maintenant ils marchent
ensemble hier social un rêve donc c'est
un une façon aussi de lire et d'écrire
autrement déficients visuels déficients
auditifs dyslexiques la médiathèque
aujourd'hui apporte cette réponse
et puis encore une fois ce réseau
associatif qui se construit cette
ouverture qu'on donne aux réseaux
associatifs nous permettent donc eu
énormément l'animation d'échangés
développement de lieux d'éducation
artistique et culturelle ont fait la
lecture et des actions pour les tout
petits
quatre mille scolaires aussi profitent
de notre oeuvre c'est également le lieu
pour un patrimoine donc pour tous grâce
aussi au digital
donc on fait on fait aussi d un travers
des ateliers donc eu de tendance
des ateliers ludiques par exemple lors
des nuits de la lecture
eh bien il des familles qui viennent et
puis qui jouent à des jeux mais les
enfants découvrent un médiathèque
et puis ils reviennent pour autre chose
peut-être pour lire pour découvrir les
ouvrages et puis surtout et enfin c'est
un accès aux ressources
dernièrement d'ailleurs françois vient
de confier au département un certain
nombre d'archivés
eux qui vont être donc
digitaliser et pour être conservés donc
beaucoup de chercheurs
beaucoup d'étudiants 3 contre plus de
13000 aujourd'hui en études supérieures
mon cher question est donc ce lieu de
ressources important pour un public très
diversifié
donc encore une fois je pense que la
médiathèque aujourd'hui et cette
médiathèque jacques chirac à 3 comme
dans d'autres de nos territoires
c'est en fait quartier type un peu de ce
que tu évoques et agnès et de ce que le
groupe évoqué en termes de réponses
structurelles on est à la croisée de
chemin et on est aussi un endroit où
l'oeuvre l'oeuvre culturelle est
accessible à tous et puis la nièvre du
coup je terminerai par la citation tout
à l'heure parce que ça nage je la garde
verrouillé au verrouillé au corps depuis
que je le suivais p 1 à 3 chambres une
métropole à lesdins d'un écrivain qui
s'appelle milan kundera un écrivain
tchèque qui est français maintenant
depuis quelques années et 18 la culture
c'est la mémoire du peuple c'est la
conscience collective de la continuité
historique et surtout c'est un mode de
pensée et est une façon surtout de vivre
je vous remercie et encore merci agnès
pour ce bel atelier auquel du m'a permis
de participer
merci mon cher didier et merci pour ton
témoignage passionnant
une dernière il ya un sujet qu'on n'a
pas suffisamment et je trouve évoqué
dans le rendu de notre réunion c'est la
défense de l'excellence et d'une
ambition culturelle pour la droite
oui on peut aider tous les territoires
mais sans pour autant rabaisser le
niveau de l'offre culturelle en fonction
des publics
moi je trouve que très souvent on diamé
la gauche elle aide les jeunes dans la
culture oui ces pans donnant un terrain
synthétique de foot que on aide à
l'offre culturelle et de ce point de vue
là je trouve que dans les territoires et
tout ce que j'ai vu moi-même en tant que
vice présidente en charge de la culture
il ya une véritable ambition culturelle
que la droite défend même quand on
apporte de la culture dans des lieux
dont habituel et je vous en ai parlé
avec les en est l'exemple de
l'excellence notamment musicale qui a
été développée ensuite par le maire du
blanc-mesnil avec
un opéra donc lyrique mais qui ensuite à
développer donc cette école de musique à
laquelle participent maintenant des
jeunes issus des milieux défavorisés
la culture permet aussi c'est ce qu'on
s'est dit de développer l'attractivité
du territoire
parce que c'est la valorisation
culturelle qui permet aussi de
développer une identité culturelle
territoriale est une compétence de son
patrimoine territorial moi je trouve
qu'on a des joyaux patrimoniaux qui sont
totalement ignorés de nos jeunes et au
sens étymologique du terme de mon
patrimoine c'est notre héritage et le
patrimoine c'est un marqueur aussi pour
la droite c'est ce qu'on transmet
transmettre notre héritage nos
traditions nos valeurs et et donc on a
parlé évidemment de la valorisation de
notre patrimoine
voilà en tout cas moi aussi j'ai envie
de terminer par une très belle citation
que j'adore du général de gaulle la
culture domine tout elle est la
condition sinequanone de notre
civilisation c'est pour ça qu'on doit de
défendre nos cultures au niveau national
en france mais aussi au niveau européen
voilà de ne pas être dilué non plus à
travers des identités qui sont pas les
nôtres mais de défendre notre culture
française soit la jeunesse à christian
et jeu d'abord on va répondre à vos
questions et je laisserais ensuite à
christian le soin de conclure
est ce que vous auriez des questions ou
un témoignage madame quand vous
souhaitez
n'embauchent pas bon d'écouter d'abord
merci aux internautes de nous avoir
suivis comme ils le font régulièrement
que ce soit l'occasion nous de nos
conventions nous facebook live et d
autres opérations que l'on peut mener
c'était un rendez vous important pour
nous et cette conférence sur la culture
n'est bien sûr ce n'est pas un
aboutissement c'est le démarrage et je
souhaite avec agnès annie et gilles qui
l'animé mais avec vous tous et vous tout
qui avaient participé et puis beaucoup
qui compte tenu des conditions
sanitaires ont pas pu nous nous nous
rejoindre que nous continuons dans cette
voie en partant comme je le disais en
introduction du terrain c'est à dire
qu'on part d'initiative très très
concrète la médiathèque jacques chirac
se l'est vu naître on a le souvient
l'inauguration son eu la chance de
l'inaugurer avec jacques chirac donc
c'est quand même un moment très très
particulier à 3 mais on a là à la fois
on a montré le côté éclectique de la
culture cet air qui a pas
la réflexion faisait didier à l'instant
de dire mais dans une commune rurale on
ne peut pas c'est faux aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'à partir du moment où on a
une approche très éclectique et bien on
crée un public qui devient de plus en
plus important et on arrive à toucher à
des catégories de personnes qu'on
imaginait pas touchés qu'ils soient
ruraux qui soit dans des quartiers
qu'ils soient plus difficiles que
d'autres
tout ça on peut le résoudre par la
culture donc ça c'est quand même
l'essentiel ce lien social qui a été
évoqué ensuite on l'a évoqué aussi c'est
très concrètement des retombées
économiques importantes
c'est des emplois qui sont ancrées et
puis c'est cet art de vie à la française
est donc de montrer que là où on en
faiblesse et où le gouvernement est en
faiblesse en ce moment en direction de
la culture parce que on peut considérer
qu'il y à là sinon des erreurs mais
plutôt des fautes politiques qui sont
faites à l'égard de la culture et bien
la sirène de nos villes nos
collectivités territoriales sont
capables de relever le défi et l'ont
montré à de nombreuses reprises donc
mais on a besoin de ce coup de pouce de
l'état c'est à dire que les
collectivités ne peuvent pas tout faire
tout seul on a je reviens pas sur les 75
% fin les trois quarts des dépenses qui
viennent des collectivités il y a besoin
d'un engagement de l'état
nous ne l'avons pas aujourd'hui et est
ce que nous voulons porter avec les
républicains dans le cadre de cette
conférence c'est vraiment montrer ce qui
est fait sur le territoire et de la
manière dont on pourrait encore le
démultiplier bien davantage s'il y avait
un accompagnement au plus haut niveau de
l'état et c'est ce que ce à quoi nous
sommes engagés dans la préparation de
ces travaux d'alternance encore une fois
merci
à toutes et à tous et à toutes à toutes
nos adjoints au maire aussi parce que il
y avait aussi des mères qui est qui
étaient là qui ont participé à ces
travaux
merci à nos trois animateurs merci aux
internautes de nous deux nous suivent et
de continuer à nous être fidèles comme
ils le sont et puis on vous donnera un
prochain rendez-vous dans l'est dans les
semaines qui viennent je n'en doute pas
parce que il faudra donner une
continuité à ses excellents travaux
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]